good after everything afternoon everyone
and welcome it's wonderful to have you
here but to invoke our Lord's presence
for our gathering today man if you'd
please remove your hats
let us pray send out your elijan your
truth let them lead us let them bring us
to your holy hill into your dwelling o
mighty o holy father how faithful you
have been to bring us to this day
you have surrounded us with so many on
whose shoulders we now stand
family friends pastors teachers coaches
and those who owe us all the best for us
you have not less have left us alone and
we thank you and here we are on the
frontier of an undiscovered country of
opportunity challenge growth and change
we are excited and terrified all at once
expectant and uncertain joyful for the
next chapter yet saddened to turn the
page things change but you remain the
same be our anchor and stay this day
this week this year confident that you
hear us and that you care we lay before
you our hopes and our dreams our fears
and our anxieties our pasts and our
futures in short our very selves souls
and bodies and all our strength and
weakness and we ask you only for your
grace to make them a fragrant and living
sacrifice pleasing to you and for your
glory all this we ask through him who
gave His life that we might live your
son our Savior Jesus Christ
together with you and the Holy Spirit
lives and reigns one God forever and
ever amen
please face the flag for me with me for
the pledge I pledge allegiance to the
flag of the United States of America and
to the Republic for which it stands one
nation
indivisible with liberty and justice for
all
please be seated
momentarily good afternoon I am David
Whalen college provost and I'll
introduce the platform party in just a
moment but I would like to inform all of
our prospective freshmen soon-to-be
freshmen and their parents that we dress
like this all summer the these are our
warm weather outfits a special thanks to
our Prelude ensemble and bagpiper and a
hearty welcome to the students and
parents of the graduating class of 2022
on the platform with me today our
president Larry arne rising seniors Ryan
Kelly Murphy and Andres Torres both of
them will speak momentarily dr. Daniel
Copeland Dean of Faculty dr. Chris Van
Orman Dean of the Natural Sciences dr.
Stephen Smith Dean of humanities dr.
Paul Marino Dean of Social Sciences dr.
RJ post rito the Graduate Dean and
Reverend Adam Rick Hillsdale College
chaplain
I said momentarily because I'm now going
to ask you to please rise with a
Hillsdale College Chamber Choir as we
sing our alma mater you are invited to
join in their conductor is our own
professor James a Holloman
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
Oh
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
just lovely thank you Jim and special
thanks to to the members of the Chamber
Choir we will now hear as promised from
our two senior students by that I don't
mean to suggest we only have two senior
students but these two are remarkable as
you will soon see I will introduce them
both first and they will speak in
succession afterwards
Ryan Kelly Murphy is a senior with a 3.8
to grade point average and she is
majoring in politics she plans to pursue
a future career as a political staffer
and a campaign manager at Hillsdale she
takes part in the soma ministries and
belongs to the Kappa Kappa Gamma
sorority the young Americans for freedom
and the College Republicans she also
works in the president's office and
serves on the radio staff she recently
won 2nd place in an Edward Everett
oratory contest and earned admission to
the George Washington fellowship program
a very rigorous and difficult program to
gain entry into she participated in the
WIPP program and interned in Washington
DC besides our College activities she
volunteers for children's ministry
project at Pine Ridge Bible Church and
she previously interned for both km o
our News and Senator Joel Anderson Ryan
Kelly is one of two children her younger
sibling attends Hillsdale the family
lives in Temecula California
her parents are self-employed unders
Torres is a senior with a 3.5 7 grade
point average his major is biology is
minors biochemistry
he plans to pursue a future career as a
physician at Hillsdale he serves on the
student Federation and belongs to the
18:44 society the Beta Beta Beta biology
honorary the outdoor adventures Club the
Sigma Zeta Science and Mathematics
honorary and the Catholic Society
Andres also volunteers at a nearby
hospital and plays on an intramural
Aska ball team and an intramural
volleyball team to cover his college
costs he works as a tutor for the
biology department and he is a resident
advisor in the Simpson dormitory he's
also a building monitor at the st.
Center for the Arts Andres is the
youngest of three children his sister
Ariel is a Hillsdale graduate and his
sister Annabelle is a university
graduate the family lives in Bloomington
Illinois his father is a manager for
State Farm
his mother is a homemaker Ryan
Thank You dr. Whelan the last time I
stood in front of this many people was
freshman year when I dropped a full
plate of food in the cafeteria welcome
parents staff faculty and most of all
welcome class of 2022 I'm excited you're
here
so are the other students and the
faculty I'm sure are especially thrilled
they now have some fresh meat to grill
in class discussions I remember sitting
in those white chairs you're in now just
three years ago with a mix of emotions
you're probably feeling the same maybe
you're nervous to start off on your own
thrilled to be starting a new chapter or
wondering what in the world have I
gotten myself into
whether you're scared out of your wits
or thinking this isn't my first rodeo
I've got this figured out
here's a little secret from me to you
I'm starting year four and I'm still
figuring life out one of my favorite
tweets I've ever read goes I didn't
realize I was supposed to know how to do
everything by my second rodeo that's
still a very low number of rodeos don't
be hard on yourself but begin this year
with a mindset that welcomes growth and
change
you're still a work in progress so am i
but Hillsdale and the people here are
going to come alongside you encourage
you teach you valuable life lessons and
challenge your mind body and spirit in
uplifting ways one thing I wish I had
been told heading into my freshman year
was how much I could expect to grow I
would like to share with you three ways
you can expect to grow during your time
at Hillsdale in your knowledge your
friendships and your character Hillsdale
is an environment that will provide you
the tools and nourishment and if you
take advantage of these things
you will mature and you will bear fruit
Hillsdale will develop your knowledge
friendships and character and prepare
you to tackle life's biggest questions
trials and triumphs but most importantly
it will prepare you to fulfill your life
purpose to love and serve God and others
the first way you can expect to grow is
in knowledge I remember getting my first
great books paperback like it was
yesterday
after class each student filed past our
professors desk to pick up our paper
with that long anticipated grade I was
excited to see my grade I mean of course
I got an A right of course I knew what I
was talking about when I wrote about
Homer's Iliad and what spurred Achilles
to go to war and then I saw it
a big fat see some of you might be
laughing to yourselves but you'll join
the first ever C Club soon enough we've
all been there just ask your RA if
they've ever gotten to see and if they
tell you no they're probably lying dr.
Arnn
once reminded us students that knowledge
is an activity not a possession I was
taken aback by those words because I'd
never considered that before but as I
made it further into my Hillsdale
education I started to understand more
about what he meant
we're not here to fill our facts our
heads with facts right a papers or
achieve that ever elusive 4.0 which I
promise you is not a life or death
matter no together we're reaching into
realms of our intellects we didn't even
know existed engaging in challenging
discussions in class and around the
lunch table we're probably not getting
the most ideal grade on a paper but
through it all we're taking part in
something much more defining to our
human experience together we're actively
learning to seek
here at Hillsdale you will learn to
pursue truth wholeheartedly and you'll
do so alongside your friends this is the
second way you can expect to grow in
your friendships it was a late night and
after a lot of studying a group of my
friends and I decided it was time for a
late night snack when we pulled up to
the McDonald's drive-through our friend
Luke ordered for us a hundred and twenty
chicken McNuggets please at first the
lady taking our order was speechless
then double and triple checked to make
sure that she correctly heard 120
chicken McNuggets and then said that
we'd have to wait while I fried up more
because there were not enough ready soon
our group of friends headed back to
campus with our precious cargo piled all
120 McNuggets onto a platter sat in a
circle and broke bread or in this case
chicken nuggets at Hillsdale there's a
reason we say it's the people as iron
sharpens iron so too will your
friendships here mold you caused you to
think deeper and teach you to act with
intention during sophomore year I broke
a bone after being bucked off a horse
and despite having a busy schedule my
friend Katie dropped everything to be by
my side at the ER be at the hospital for
my surgery and take care of me during my
recovery that was selfless love and that
same servant heartedness is something
I've seen in so many more of my peers at
Hillsdale College look forward to having
those friendships and strive yourself to
be that friend the third way you can
expect to grow is in character
once you say goodbye to your parents
later today you'll be faced with choices
these next four years that are entirely
your own will you pursue your faith will
you seek out friends that uplift you and
help you grow I'd encourage you join a
dorm Bible study even if a Bible study
is something that you've never tried
before seek out a home church make your
faith your own and serve others each day
especially in small ways in Colossians 3
you and I are called to follow this
example and I think it's the perfect way
to set the tone for the coming school
year clothe yourselves with compassion
kindness humility gentleness and
patience forgive as the Lord forgave you
and over all these virtues put on love
which binds them all together in perfect
unity when you focus on putting others
first the development of your character
will follow find a table at lunch where
somebody is sitting by themselves ask
them where they're from what brought
them here and in a few minutes
you'll have a new friend instead of
joking with your friends by putting
others down be the one that finds the
good in others and always has an
encouraging word to share CS Lewis wrote
in mere Christianity
surely when a man does when he has taken
off his guard is the best evidence for
what sort of man he is
in the next four years you're going to
be taken off your guard a lot but don't
be discouraged because it will test
challenge and build your character as we
say here at Hillsdale College virtuse
tenth ami-nee Gaudet strength rejoices
in the challenge rejoice in this
challenge ahead of you rejoice in this
growth and if you drop a plate of food
in
the cafeteria in front of everybody
learn to laugh at yourself take
everything in stride and know that we
are all growing together thank you
[Applause]
welcome Hillsdale College class of 2022
today I will offer advice on how to make
the most of your Hillsdale College
experience I'll begin by telling you a
little bit about my family the years
1961 in the setting is post communist
revolution Cuba my grandparents decided
to take a risk they chose to flee their
homeland and seek asylum in the United
States of America they did not speak
English my grandmother was seven months
pregnant and they could only leave with
five dollars each with a total of ten
dollars and the generosity of strangers
and friends they built a life there of
themselves in freedom you're probably
asking yourselves how this relates to
you and how this helps you make the most
of your time at Hillsdale I have three
words for you experience risk and reward
please look around you what do you see
well what I see is diversity yes at
Hillsdale College we have diversity our
diversity is not based on the color of
our skin our diversity is based on the
unique experiences of each person who
attends this College you may not have
fled your country in search of a life of
freedom but nonetheless your experiences
are valuable and they make you who you
are
there are over fourteen hundred students
faculty and staff who want to make you
part of the Hillsdale College experience
the Hillsdale College legacy so please
do not just make friends with in your
grade meet sophomores upperclassmen and
professors who desire to desire to share
their experience with you it is from
this partnership of students and staff
faculty that we make our institution
great but this does not come easily this
is where you must accept risk over the
next four years you will experience what
makes Hillsdale different and that will
require you to take chances you're
entering an environment that will
challenge you you will lose sleep and at
times you may lose heart yet the people
around you will teach you how to pick
yourself back up from failure and with
your added experience we become stronger
and I say we to emphasize that we are
together in this pursuit of what is good
those are the risks you must take for
academic success but college is more
than academics it is a place to learn
outside the classroom as well
so put yourself out there speak to the
person you don't know in your great
books class join in a new club pick up a
new hobby without risk there is no
reward so please take risks when you
fall like we all do we're peers and
professors will help you stand back up
to take on your next risk like my
grandparents when they left their
homeland unsure of their future you must
take this risk to make yourself stronger
and to make this community stronger you
will reap the reward of your hard work
you are the class of 2022 and we need
you to continue the legacy that is
Hillsdale College when you are in need
come to us your fellow students and
teachers and we will help you stand
before our close I thought it important
to share some experiences from other
current students at Hillsdale they've
both chosen to remain anonymous the two
experienced are from seniors one says I
went from one of the smartest kids in
high school to just an average Hillsdale
student which is still great by the way
the transition was brutal and caused
many headaches but by the beginning of
my junior year I came to understand who
I am and became secure and confident to
take on the world
Hillsdale is transforming me it has been
one incredible life-changing journey
many of you have similar stories to this
whether it be that you were the smartest
most athletic most athletic or most
artistically talented but you are in a
bigger world now and we will work to
make you better
the second senior says as a freshman
coming into Hillsdale I didn't own my
Catholic faith it was simply something
handed down to me from my parents the
first couple of weeks I took the risk of
going to different events though I did
not feel worthy of going because I
wasn't as faithful as everyone else but
by going to these events I met other
people from a similar background and we
were able to confide in each other our
lack of knowledge in our faith and I was
able to grow in my faith alongside them
as you embark on this journey through
Hillsdale and may be the first time that
some of you are away from your parents
for any significant portion of your life
you will have to make your own decisions
and choose how to live your life as you
learn your experiences will contribute
to the Hillsdale College legacy we need
you to make your own experiences here we
need you to take your own risks here I
am proud to welcome you to Hillsdale
College class of 2022 god bless you on
your journey
Thank You Ryan and Andrews a few
housekeeping details after convocation
students are asked to join their adviser
groups immediately to the rear of this
assembly if you turn around and look
behind you you see a little sea of green
t-shirts perspiring green t-shirts those
are those are students who will hold up
your advisors name just find your
advisor we've asked the students not to
shift back and forth so it shouldn't be
a moving target and the advisor groups
will meet immediately after this this
this convocation parents are in turn
invited to dinner in the Sorrell center
the Sorrell center is located on the
west side of campus right behind us is
the Student Union if you go past the
Student Union further west on the other
side of the quad and a little bit that
way you will find the sural Center
perhaps it's easier just to follow the
crowd of people they'll find it as well
it's now my pleasure to introduce the
12th president of Hillsdale College dr.
Larry Arne thank you
be patient dr. Arnn received his BA in
1974 from Arkansas State University
graduating with the highest distinction
he received his MA in government in 1976
and his PhD in government in 1985 from
the Claremont Graduate School he also
studied in England from 1977 to 1980
first as a research student
international history at the London
School of Economics and then in modern
history at Worcester College Oxford
University while in England he also
served as director of research for the
late Sir Martin Gilbert the official
biographer of Winston Churchill he
returned to the United States in 1980 to
become an editor for public research
syndicated and from 1985 to 2000 he
served as president of the Claremont
Institute an education and research
institution based in Southern California
while at Claremont he was the founding
chairman of the California Civil Rights
initiative which was passed by
California voters in 1996 and which
prohibits racial preferences in state
hiring contracting and admissions dr.
Aaron is on the board of directors of
the Heritage Foundation the Heritage
Salvatori center of Claremont McKenna
College the intercollegiate Studies
Institute and the Claremont Institute he
served on the US Army War College Board
of Visitors for two years for which he
earned the Department of the Army's
outstanding civilian service medal in
2015 dr. Arnn received the Bradley cries
from the Lynde and Harry Bradley
Foundation he is a member of the
American Political Science Association
the International Churchill Society the
Mont Pelerin Society the Philadelphia
society and the philanthropy roundtable
published in white published widely in
national newspapers magazines and
periodicals on issues of Public Policy
history and political theory is the
author of three books Liberty and
learning the evolution of American
education the founders key the divine
and natural connection between the
Declaration and the Constitution and
what we risk by losing it and
Churchill's trial
Winston Churchill in the salvation of
free government in addition to serving
as president dr. Arnn is professor
politics in history at Hillsdale
teaching courses on Aristotle on Winston
Churchill and on the American
Constitution dr. Arnn is also editor of
the Churchill documents a sub Series in
the official biography of Winston
Churchill begun in 1962 by Randolph
Churchill and now published by Hillsdale
College press the the official biography
of Winston Churchill is the largest of
its kind and under dr. Oren's direction
will grow to a total of 31 volumes dr.
Arnn and his wife Penelope have four
children Katie
Henry Alice and Tony now please join me
in welcoming dr. Larry our welcome to
you all
thank you Jim Holloman and the Chamber
Choir
more than a third of our students are in
music and anybody who wants to can be in
the choir just not in that choir
those are the ones who can actually sing
that was David Whelan who thinks that
Ryan Murphy's name is Ryan Kelly you
could see why you'd think that they're
both mattresses I'll get out I want you
to meet my wife because she's the nicest
person here and the only one makes me
look good and she's sitting right there
and you can call her any time and she'll
help your kid stand up
I want to point out that under
understand Rion Rion we're great is one
knew they would be Andres is a very
honorable young man and you have to know
him for a year or two before you figure
out he has a sense of humor
but he does whereas that shows more with
Ryan and I noticed that her sister is
sitting down there and I was pleased to
see that and then I noticed her mother
and I was pleased to see that because I
thought there was another Murphy coming
here and then I noticed the boyfriend
the useless Michael Clarke and I said no
they're not there's not another Murphy
there's no more Murphy's are there mrs.
Murphy well I commend you to think about
making some more listen anyway mom is
here to watch Ryan show off today and
Michael clerk is hoping that Ryan won't
dump him as would be correct
for your parents of course this day's a
mixed blessing you gotta cry mom's no no
no that's bull talk it's very proud
isn't it look what they've become
they're tall they're self-contained
they're attractive people it's smart
they work hard they're used to it
they've chosen this and you know this is
weird for a reason I'm gonna tell when I
get to you seniors it's very weird very
different when people ask me what
undress said you have diversity at
Hillsdale College I always say yeah but
I'm working on it
why because the only kind of diversity
that matters in a college is what you
think and we disagree you all the time
around here and that means somebody's
wrong the one agreement you cannot make
in a college is to disagree we're here
to figure that out and that's what makes
it complicated that's what makes it
challenging so let makes it hard you'll
soon see you freshmen but to stick with
your parents your child has chosen this
and you know your child got in here
probably everywhere they went they were
told you know you're just God's gift to
man and you'll be the smartest kid we
ever got and you're just gonna go on to
become anything you want to be and what
are we saying well it ain't quite like
that is it so you got to be proud of
that and I commend you for that and of
course something's lost because this is
the point of your life in the most
immediate sense the highest thing in
life might not be family but family is
the foundation for all the rest of that
and now there's going to be something
missing from your house it'll get worse
because I'm sorry you have to drive home
alone tonight
after we break up this in just very
short while then those kids in the green
up they're going to take your kid away
and the next time you talk to them on
the phone they will probably pretend to
be sad that you're gone and by the way I
commend you to do that
and they'll slip when they come home at
Christmas and the holiday which is
pretty long will draw toward an end and
they'll mention their time almost time
to go back home and that'll be kind of
upsetting to you that's all gonna happen
happened to me and Penny happen to
everybody except these kids up here on
this stage
oh yeah the chaplain hadn't had any kids
yet but he has his instructions
you get compensations here one of them
is we will tell you things we will send
your your child's graves to you address
to you if we took the money from the
government that would be illegal that's
one of the advantages not doing that
there are so very many it's just you
have to do without the money I guess is
why it's why everybody doesn't do it
here's another one if your kid gets in
trouble we'll call you and talk to you
about it it's not common for a student
here to get in trouble discipline
trouble but you know they get down
because Andra said is this you know the
average in our grade point average here
is 3.9 I think it might be 3 8 9 this
year by the prediction of the admissions
people well the average first one grade
point average is about 2.8 and then it
rises from there and that's stress and
people who have because you know how
hard they've worked to get what they've
got and now they're not gonna get that
and it'll be a crisis and some of them
we don't pay much to that one of the
reason we go on and on take
right now hard it is what odors these
people right here are you know I mean
they're awful but do not major in
English or physics or accounting or
anything it's all a terrible mess right
and and you're gonna have to learn that
it's just something else not what you've
seen I'll tell you what that is in a
minute but parents we expect success we
have a rule inside the administration
that I will say in front and the faculty
in front of your child for the only time
and that is if your child fails it's our
fault we will take responsibility for it
on the other hand if you fail you will
fail we'll just feel really bad about it
later and try to fix it you get to me
you got to come to parents weekend it's
the coolest thing we get in the fall
parents weekend we usually get about 900
parents I've been to two to two of my
children didn't they they went to Brand
X and then one of them foolish girl did
it because I don't work here and regrets
it today because most of her Tempe
teachers are sitting up on the stage
right now but I went to parents weekend
at those places and there were 60 at one
of them and 80 at when I'm same size
place near 900 come here in the fall
maybe six seven hundred in the spring
why do they come you get to sit for 10
minutes with every one of them and they
will tell you what they think of your
kid and you can make suggestions and you
will tell them you know oh please take
care of my kid we always say oh we
really well and we will but if something
goes wrong you'll hear from us you are
welcome here you will be informed
suggestions are welcome you'll find that
as I'm about to explain to your children
in just a minute we have some idea what
we're doing around here
and we don't really think we have very
many choices to make about it we think
this is a kind of thing that it's the
right thing it always has been always
will be
we even think it's the best thing and we
think there's a way to go about doing it
and we practice that all the time and
we're okay and we're getting better so
some of you will think that we're not
doing some fundamental thing the right
way and you'll find out that we're
pretty stubborn but we'll explain I want
you to come back be in touch
because I'll explain later at parents
weekend especially you parents are
joining something here because the thing
your child is about to swear to do today
and tomorrow that thing is going to take
your child the rest of his life never be
finished with it make every aspect of
his life better if he does it right and
it means it's changing your life
starting right now today and you will
always be part of that change you should
value it you should treat us like the
friends and partners we hear today come
would you parents of the class of 22
stand up so we can see you please thank
thank you very much welcome it's a lot
of you gracious to the class of 2022
would you stand up please
let's see you
you are any of you finding it too warm
out here today
hold up your hand yeah cuz there's no
winning it Hillsdale College thank you
sit down
see lesson 1 there was some talk in the
administration I learned about it from
Provost Whalen about moving in inside
where we do have a wonderful
air-conditioned room huge and beautiful
and stays very cool and there's flowing
cool water in the back you missed that
we didn't do that because we knew you'd
want to here's what you need to know you
to these two things you students this is
really only one thing to do here find
out what things are you think you know
you don't you're too young to know also
education doesn't work the right way
you're gonna go through Socrates educate
educate kind of he gave in the dialogues
and it's gonna start right away and it's
gonna start in every discipline you're
gonna go into class and you're gonna say
something and somebody's gonna say what
does that mean my favorite goes like
this I do it in the dining hall all the
time and they never expected I say what
are you doing and they saying this and I
say why are you doing that and you never
need more than two questions for the
Gipper did more to get them to say that
this is a good thing to do I'm doing
this because this is good which is the
only reason by the way did we ever do
anything and then I asked what is it for
a thing to be good and they all memorize
Aristotle's answer cuz they know I teach
that here and I like that answer I even
think it's the right one and then when
they give that answer I disagree with
them Aristotle's answer is it's the
being of each thing when it is being
fully and most excellently itself like a
good human being is like a good
racehorse has all the good of that thing
although those two things are different
of course
and then they learn to say that and
they've learned something and then when
you disagree with that then they see
this argument is going to have to become
my own I must know this and everything
like it and there are so many things
like that you will discover toward the
end maybe only toward the end of your
life but you are obliged now your key to
your undertaking something parents do
you know how much this cost I mean us
it's about twice the tuition and we've
charged almost nobody full tuition why
do we do that we do it for the joy of it
we want your kid we want the kid that'll
stand they'll come in here in the heat
and hear me talk hard and think this is
gonna be great because you're never
gonna learn these things that will
enrich your life and make you a blessing
to everyone you meet unless you are
prepared to give your whole being to it
that means doesn't matter if you're
tired you only rest because it's a
judgement that you need to and you'll
get more done if you do you want to
become a serious person this is a Greek
word for that spewed Isles
big word you learned in Aristotle the
serious person one of my teachers Martin
Gilbert's a Church biographer if I would
ask him to meet somebody he would say is
that a serious person and if I said yes
to that he would meet them you know
later when I was kind of grown up and he
was more famous even when I work for him
and I love that word and I said yeah
that's that word and Aristotle isn't it
that's our that's why we're here we are
going to learn the meaning of things the
being of things the good of things
things natural and the natural
scientists thing
in the humanities we have for ceremonies
like this year the last ones called
commencement is for the seniors why do
we call it commencement commencing the
life that you are here undertaking to
prepare yourself to commence four years
from now it will move in a heartbeat
do not waste a day the second or third
are called convocation and they're like
this there are these rituals just like
this you notice it's formal we're
wearing our robes because it's too cold
for us and the robes denote status rank
when you get your fourth year to commit
but you'll get your rank you'll get your
robe to signify your rank and you'll
have it for the rest of your life you
must think ahead to that because you
need to qualify yourself for that and by
the time you get there I promise as you
just heard Ryan and Andres say you will
understand now that you are more
ignorant than you thought you were and
you still are and in that you will be
wiser you mustn't waste time we're in an
order here you're gonna find that you
can argue anything here that you can
argue in a civil and academic manner
where's the limit you're not to be
violating the moral code we're supposed
to be just and moderate and brave we
have to cultivate those things because
none of us is those things perfectly
also the college has a right to do what
it was built to do and I can assure you
it has no purpose right now today not in
any trustee not in me not in any of
these faculty members except to do what
it was built to do almost 175 years ago
and so of course none of you will seek
to obstruct the college from doing what
it's supposed to do I'll tell a little
story about that so we had mike pence
for commencement last year and that was
controversial and everywhere that mine
go that man goes he's demonstrated
against Ryan was an end
had last spring and she was the head of
the advanced team for the vice president
of the United States at her alma mater
and one person on the advance said to me
said well the kids will probably
demonstrate against him on the stage and
I said you know I don't think so
and he said do they all like him and I
said I don't know much them don't know
him I said but do they all support him I
doubt it I know a lot large number who
don't that isn't what it's about is it
we require to pursue this life that we
pursue to live in a regime of civil and
religious freedom just as we pray at the
beginning of this ceremony we say the
Pledge grateful that at least right now
nobody's going to come and arrest us for
what we stay say here and tyrants do not
like things like this because they're
full of questions and they're always
teaching everybody to look up higher and
higher and of course that means well
beyond even the highest human being we
have a right to do that here now what
you have to do is you have to become a
partner in this the word college means
partnership you can't function together
every human community rights the
philosopher is organized for some
purpose and we must share the purpose
and you must do that today starting now
today you're going to take a pledge with
your parents that's going to commit them
by the way and us and tomorrow you will
hand in your honor code or else you'll
go home on Tuesday and that's not
anything except this this is the kind of
work that can only be done with a full
commitment of mind and heart
I want you to absorb that it'll change
your life
it'll make you great it'll do it by
making you good it's the only thing that
can do that we are all going to do that
together and I promise we're gonna be
stubborn about it none of us is going to
be deterred
welcome class of 2020 - thank you dr.
Arnn as we come to the end of this
ceremony I would like to ask all
students and parents please to stand as
we dedicate ourselves to the high
purpose before us the purpose about
which you just heard this is an
important transition in your lives and
it is proper that we should acknowledge
and declare this commitment inside your
program you will find the Hillsdale
College matriculation ceremony pledge as
representative of the faculty I will
read the first part we ask the freshman
to respond by reading in unison the
second part titled matriculates I'll ask
Ryan and Andres to come up to the podium
with me and they will join you in that
portion of the reading right
founded in gratitude for the blessings
of civil and religious liberty Hillsdale
College is a seat of higher learning
here on these grounds generations have
given themselves to the pursuit of truth
the love of wisdom and the grace of
intelligent piety here in these halls
generations have come to perpetuate the
high calling of learning and the noble
love of the good in gratitude still and
in concert with these generations
together we pledge ourselves anew to
this great purpose Hillsdale College in
its zeal for learning and its embrace of
academic integrity and honorable conduct
commits to students all the talents
knowledge and intelligence with which it
is graced educating by precept and
example it is dedicated to the liberal
education of students in whom it trusts
that learning will rise to wisdom and
that virtue will be blessed with
strength we the students of Hillsdale
College commit ourselves to the diligent
study and patient reflection having come
to learn we are proud to do so with
integrity and will conduct ourselves
with exemplary honor as a sacrifices
past and present may make possible our
education we to become stewards of this
College what are the generations yet to
come we pledge ourselves to the pursuit
of truth the love of the good and the
cultivation of beauty for the sake of
our minds in the hearts and for our any
noble Society by doing so we embrace the
high calling of liberal education this
pledge bespeaks our unity in a great
purpose intellectual and moral wisdom
blessed by God is the foundation of a
good and humane life and the necessary
condition for enduring Liberty may God
bless us now
and always as we illuminate our minds
refine our passions and seek the good
parents please turn to your sons and
daughters now officially Hillsdale
College students and give them your
blessing
please remain standing for the
benediction following which there is a
some benediction we can remain standing
for that and then the recessional
chaplain
and now may God bless you and keep you
the Lord make his face to shine upon you
and be gracious to you the Lord lift up
his countenance upon you and give you
peace and the blessing of God Almighty
Father Son and Holy Spirit be among you
and remain with you always
amen
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]